[Music]
you said man won't see me
ali all back can't come in here
what is he white oh boy
[Music]
we're sending a man that works in an
office to pick something up
you are part of a babysitting team
watching his family while he does it
good morning everything is normal
except what do you want is that
something you'd say
normal monday i'm gonna shoot you right
now
can i go home now wait at the house
after what do you mean after
but right off to you
what is going on big guy yeah what are
we doing we're following instructions
are you helping me or are you not
helping no no no no
thank you set up man
god called me offering me ten thousand
dollars
turn you in fifteen for the white guy i
think he's the only one to make a move
i can make a move too have the keys
i'd like to listen to the radio
well i guess that's the 64 000 question
it's been a long day i'll put this over
you so i can relax thank you
you have a good time
we had a little slip up at work
i don't think that's the end of that
chicken now oh problem is you're not
smart enough to know how not smart you
are
which makes you unpredictable which
makes you untrustworthy
why are you doing this man cause i'ma
get what's mine
i'm sorry i'm gonna punch you now sir
i'm punching you
this is going to be a punch
[Music]
[Music]
you